all of us know what a number line is and
the numbers we see here on the number
line are called integers on the right
side of zero we have positive integers
and on its left we have negative
integers integers we are familiar with
but what about numbers like these 1 by 3
5 by 6 or - 7 by 12
each of these are numbers but we don't
use them as often as we use counting
numbers such numbers are called rational
numbers but we need to define them well
we cannot say numbers like these are
rational numbers we say that they are of
the form P by Q 1 number in the
numerator and 1 in the denominator but
there are a few conditions we need to
know P and Q should be integers we can
have only integers in place of P and Q
and there is another important condition
Q should not be equal to zero why do we
have the second condition say I asked
you to calculate 3 / 0 what would be the
quotient 0 multiplied by what will give
you 3 there is no such number this value
is undefined so this is the basic
definition of rational numbers it is a
number of the form P by Q where P and Q
are integers and Q is not equal to 0
there are many questions that should pop
up in your head when you see this
definition what is the difference
between rational numbers and fractions
are integers classified as rational
numbers what about 0 how do we plot such
numbers on a number line and how do we
compare two rational numbers for example
if you are asked to compare 1 and 5 you
could easily say that 5 is greater of
the two but what if you are asked to
compare numbers like 6 by 7 and 13 by 15
how would you find out which one is
greater don't worry about it all these
questions will be answered in our videos
on rational numbers